hace cinco años para motas hija hice una
de las mayores apuestas de su carrera el
propietario de varias tiendas y
restaurantes del wanda invirtió 75 mil
dólares en tu poca la primera empresa de
reparto a domicilio en angola hoy la
plataforma es un éxito con mil pedidos
al día y franquicias en toda la región
este clip problema su área últimamente
petróleo aquí más allá de los diamantes
y el petróleo todavía hay muchos
sectores en los que se puede invertir si
tienes una idea que aún no se ha
desarrollado aquí y que funciona bien en
otros lugares hay potencial para crear
un negocio
ese es el negocio sin embargo este
potencial no se ha aprovechado del todo
la economía angoleña sigue rezagada a
pesar de las ambiciosas reformas como la
flotación de la moneda nacional y la
consolidación fiscal tras cinco años de
recesión en 2021 volvió el crecimiento
económico pero la inflación es hoy del
25% y la tasa de paro subió del 24 al 30
por ciento en sango a las afueras de
luanda christina está sin trabajo desde
marzo
desde que perdí mi trabajo es muy
difícil pagar el alquiler las tasas
escolares de los niños en la
electricidad es muy complicado porque mi
marido es el único que tiene trabajo y
su sueldo no alcanza para pagar todo
ahora mismo aún no hemos pagado el
alquiler
en 2017 el presidente joão lourenço fue
elegido con la promesa de realizar un
milagro económico diversificar la
economía y crear medio millón de puestos
de trabajo el gobierno culpa la pandemia
de los retrocesos pero para este
economista no es la única razón
angola es uno de los 20 peores países
para hacer negocios en el mundo no hay
ninguna infraestructura tenemos un
sistema educativo deficiente así que
mientras el estado se niega a abordar
estos problemas ya dejar que el sector
privado se encargue del resto no
podremos diversificar nuestra economía
estado resto pero sector privado no es
no podemos diversificar el cual en
angola el crudo sigue representando el
30 por ciento del pib y el 90 por ciento
de los ingresos por exportaciones